hey y'all so it is pretty gross today in
DC
um not at all a good day to go out for a
walk but I'm going to go for a walk
nonetheless because I am pretty deep in
my feels about some stuff these past few
weeks and um
feeling like a walk would do me some
good and hey why not share some of those
thoughts with you as I'm on that walk
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
this is definitely going to be one of
those videos that focuses more on the
brain but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinsky and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission alright so
full disclosure this is not actually the
video that I thought I was going to be
sharing with you all today
um I actually did shoot a video last
week that was all about uh why I'm not
doing the POI top 10 list this year
and
um connected together some dots about
some observations that I've had about uh
flow Arts culture in the past few years
and
I don't think the video is very good
like don't get me wrong I go and visit a
very beautiful place and share it with
all of you which I think is great
and you know the ideas behind it I think
are good and definitely like it touches
on something called the validation
economy I did not come up with that word
but it's a great one for it that has
been kind of swimming around in my head
for years now that I really wanted to
expound on at some point but I think
that was maybe the wrong place to do it
in but it's also part of what's turned
out to be kind of a trend lately
um you know a couple weeks ago I
uploaded a video about a piece that I'm
choreographing which you know I'm at a
point now where I'm almost done with
that and I just keep having this
question go through my head about it and
it's the same question that I had going
through my head when it came to that
video that I recorded last week about
the top 10 list
is this actually any good like I've
spent several months now trying to
choreograph this piece it started off as
just me like improvising around a song
that I really liked and a few ideas that
I thought were important and now it's at
a point where as I'm looking at it I'm
like okay I'm within side of the finish
line
but I'm also looking at all the pieces
and being like do these actually add up
to anything like is there actually a
story or through line to this is this
just me randomly vomiting up bits and
pieces of movement choreography and do
they even have anything remotely
resembling a coherent emotional
statement coming out of them
it almost makes me tempted to be honest
with you to like scrap the whole thing
and start over like take some of the
choreography that I have and try and
build it into something that has a
slightly more coherent narrative to it
rather than just being streamed together
all these individual moments that I
thought looked really cool on video of
course this isn't the first time if I
have wondered if the stuff that I have
created is any good and have serious
doubts about it and full disclosure it
also must be said that um I am
definitely in the initial stages of the
seasonal depression that tends to visit
me every fall and winter
and wondering if the stuff that I'm
producing is any good is a regular
fixture of those States so it is
entirely possible that this is me up in
my head but I don't think it entirely is
you know for one thing when it comes to
the top 10 list video and talking about
the validation economy even I have to
admit as I'm going back through the edit
that like these ideas are connected only
very tentatively and more than anything
else it seems like one of those moments
where I was trying to have a teachable
moment around something that I was
working on and I didn't quite think of
how well the connective tissue was going
to draw together for that and I don't
know the dance piece that I'm working on
is based around a lot of stuff that
happened to me over the summer that just
quite frankly wasn't very emotionally
positive for me and so maybe the fact
that they are a bunch of seemingly
disconnected moments is a part of what
makes the piece really reflect what it
was to live through that period but like
the piece that I always wrestle with is
that the stuff that I put out there into
the world isn't just for me it's also
for all of you out there watching
I have to serve all of you and yes I
have to serve myself and sometimes I run
into conflicts with that because I
definitely have my own beliefs about
like what I produce being good versus
not but frequently I discovered that my
beliefs about what I think makes good
content don't always line up with that
same belief for you while out there
watching of course legendarily several
years ago I almost quit doing this
channel because a flow video that I
thought was so bad it shouldn't be
posted and wound up posting anyway
simply because my content schedule was
empty wound up being the most popular
thing I posted all year so very
frequently there's a disconnect between
what I think is good and what some of
you all out there think is good and you
know it's a thing that is a content
creator it kind of comes baked into the
pudding so to speak you know like there
are some videos that I just absolutely
feel like I've made a huge creative leap
with you know last week my video on
achieving Perfection was definitely one
of those I thought that I grew so much
as both a producer as well as an editor
in creating that video and it kind of
only did so so in terms of reaction
through the audience
it's weird how that works so part of me
is like maybe I should just release the
things and let the audience decide for
themselves whether what I produce is any
good or not after all like the audience
is ultimately the judge of what we
enshrine in our culture as being the
stuff that we think of as being
representative of a particular art or
movement and there's a part of me that
wants to hold on to it and think like
okay how can I put this out there in a
way that like I think is good regardless
of what happens on the other end you
know especially with that piece that
I've been choreographing in my head I'm
almost tempted to do both like to
release the version of it as is and then
try to go back through and rewrite it
with more formal structure to it and
like actually compose it in more ways
and just see what comes out of that see
how people feel about having these two
different options for what this piece
can be that's also going to be a whole
heck of a lot of work though you know
what part of that tattoo is that I'm
trying to do some things with POI dance
that I've never done before in terms of
expressing emotion in a very very raw
Manner and choreographing around that
usually when I choreograph I'm just like
doing stuff on the counts and this is
very much not a piece that works like
that it's very expressionistic in that
regard and you know I can't expect that
the first piece that I write like this
is necessarily going to be a masterpiece
sometimes it takes you a few bits and
pieces to get to where you're trying to
go and you know having some Works in
progress don't quite make it to the you
know Apex of your expectations it's not
the worst thing to have to go through in
order to get there and of course
ultimately I could just be up in my own
head about all of this and it is just
depression brain kicking in and telling
me that the stuff that I'm doing is not
as good as I would hope it to be
sometimes it's hard to tell for the time
being though I do think that I'm going
to rework the video about the top 10 and
the validation economy into probably two
separate videos either that I'm going to
try like writing a script for it
formally and see if I can really connect
the dots in written form if I can't then
they should definitely be two different
videos
um
yeah and I hopefully will finish up
choreographing that POI piece in the
next week here and we'll see how I feel
about advancing it to a point where I
share it with the world right
buddy what do you all think do you sit
around wondering if the stuff that you
produce is any good do you worry about
how it's going to be received by the
world and do you worry that there is a
disconnect between what you think is
good and what other people think is good
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment
subscribe and share both to help other
people find this video as well as to
help keep the conversation going and to
help my channel grow this video would
not be possible we're not for the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible thank you
one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
like the videos that I produce and are
not currently a supporter and would like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you will
be helping me out in my mission to try
and bring POI spending and flow Arts to
The Wider world and help people connect
their brains and their bodies as
creative individuals go check that out
please and thank you and if you want to
watch more videos where I'm deep in my
feelings and talking to the camera about
flow arts and the feelings that it
brings up while I've got a whole bunch
of other videos on that topic I will
link to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube also based
upon your past viewing habits the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like this top video too so maybe
give that a look as well in the meantime
uh try and get out at least a little bit
even if the weather is pretty yucky this
walk did indeed improve my improve my
mood away bets and I will see you with a
new video on Wednesday then yeah thanks
for watching
peace